hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and this is the 2021 edition of
the holiday message here at mindscape
the original idea of the holiday message
was i wanted to take a couple weeks off
near the holiday times to just you know
clear the mind of podcast oriented
questions and so i took one week off
where in between christmas and new
year's that makes sense and just before
christmas i didn't quite have the energy
to do it but i thought i should reward
all the wonderful people who are
listening here every week with at least
some message to express my appreciation
that's the real job of the holiday
message is to say thank you
to all the many people who've tuned into
mindscape couldn't do it without you
well that's not true i could do it
without the audience it might be harder
to get guests but i could do something
it wouldn't be nearly as much fun and i
probably wouldn't do it if no one were
listening so you play a very important
role here by listening uh and the
original idea also with the holiday
message was to maybe
do a state of the podcast address right
to talk about what we did over the last
year the different guests we had i found
that that was number one work which i
didn't want to do and number two was
hard to do because i
talked to a lot of different people
about a lot of different things it
seemed cheating in some way to try to
boil it down to a few themes and i
thought that even if i mentioned like
some of my favorite podcasts others
would get lost or insulted or whatever
they're all good i love all my children
equally so what has actually happened
over the years over the couple years
is that the holiday message has morphed
into a kind of mini solo episode where i
just talk about something i'm interested
in talking about
um and so today that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna try to keep it mini i always
say this is gonna be short and then
things get longer because i don't know i
like to hear the sound of my own voice i
suppose but um the topic this year of
the holiday message is disciplines that
is to say disciplines within academia
and also cocktails like you drink at a
bar
now you might be wondering what do
disciplines and cocktails have to do
with each other
only one way to find out let's go
[Music]
let me give a slightly deeper
version of the thought process that went
into choosing the topic for this year's
holiday message
one of the things that did come up as a
theme in the episodes over the year and
also other discussions i've been having
elsewhere is the idea of agency
agency in the sense that a person an
agent
has the ability has some power in the
world right some influence over the
world
uh some causal
impact on what happens in the universe
around them and this happens at a level
of sort of philosophy where does agency
come from do we have free will things
like that it certainly is a crucial
concept in complex systems research
where you do
agent-based modeling a big
idea in complex systems research is that
rather than you know doing
thermodynamics or statistical mechanics
and treating every atom as a simple
system that bumps into every other atom
you treat the individual pieces making
up your complex systems as themselves
somewhat complex right agent-based
modeling you let the individual
sub-pieces have their own agency and of
course it's crucially important the idea
of agency in politics today
if anything as i've talked about
democracy in politics on the podcast and
elsewhere i've been more and more struck
with how many of our current political
problems come down to people not
thinking that they have a voice that
they have any impact you know they can
vote but what difference does it make
the politicians are all the same and it
causes them to lash out in different
ways and it causes the common project of
democracy to hit uh
some roadblocks some potholes along the
way as you might have been might have
noticed that we are actually
meeting right now so
uh
i've been thinking about this like what
gives people uh a feeling of agency is
it true that we should try to get that
feeling is it people have too much
agency whatever it is so occasionally
like if something is not worthy of a
whole deep thought i'll just put it out
there on twitter to see what the
responses are so a couple months ago i
put out a tweet saying something like
if you want to
understand a position
whether you know a position in science
or politics or history or whatever i
said the first thing to do
is to get it from the mouths of the
people who actually hold that position
that is to say rather than learning
about an idea from its opponents
learn about the idea from its advocates
not and take that as the final word but
at least understand why these people
would believe this right that sounds
like a sensible way to learn a
potentially controversial position
first try to understand why anyone in
the world would believe this and you're
not going to get that without listening
to the actual people so that you see
where it's related a bit to agency like
listen to what the people are actually
saying rather than trying to put words
in their mouth
i thought this was an incredibly boring
tweet that was almost you know a cliche
and would uh be ignored but a mini
eruption came in the comments to that
particular tweet people did not agree
with me
that you should learn ideas or
come to understand them learn is not
even the right word but you know it's
not like you're learning some new bit of
science necessarily but why do people
hold this idea listen to the people who
hauled it right that was my suggestion
and people didn't like that suggestion
many people didn't like it it's always
hard to know on twitter what people are
actually thinking because it's a very
very tiny minority of people who are
speaking and there's all sorts of biases
that come into who comments etc but it
was clear that a lot of people
basically said well what about the bad
ideas i don't want to learn the bad
ideas from the people who actually hold
those bad ideas what about the nazis and
the racists you're not telling me i
should read what those people wrote to
understand them they're bad and we know
they're bad we don't have to think any
more about them
i didn't you know i don't generally go
back and forth on twitter i don't use
twitter as a medium of uh discourse and
conversation because it's really ill
suited for that uh
but
if i had i would have said yes
especially for the bad ideas because
it's the bad ideas it's the ideas that
make our skin crawl and seem a little
bit horrifying to us
that it takes the most work to
understand why anyone would ever hold
them right if an idea is attractive and
basically good sounding then we can more
or less work out why someone would hold
that idea whereas if an idea is kind of
horrible to us
uh if we want to understand why anyone
would ever hold that we need to talk to
them you know or read what they've
written try to think uh get a view into
their mind and think about why they
would have come to such a conclusion
um but it's clear that it's not uh
just a few people but but quite a large
number of people who think that there's
something wrong about being exposed to
radically different ideas from the
horse's mouth like maybe it will poison
you or maybe like we already know ahead
of time we don't need to understand that
etc
i don't feel that way so that was the
first idea for a holiday message to talk
about agency and the importance of
talking to people with very very
different ideas than we have
and this morphed as i thought about it i
said well you know maybe this is just a
specific case of the more general
example uh that we should engage with
people who are intellectually from
elsewhere right people who come from
very different points of view not just
politically or whatever but academically
as well you know people who like many
worlds should talk to people who like
pilotwave theories or epistemic models
of quantum mechanics and so on string
theory should talk to quantum gravity
people
this is something i also believe i'm a
big believer in interdisciplinary
engagement and and cross
platform and
cross-positional
talk so that you can better understand
why in the world these other people
would have these crazy ideas you can't
figure it out for yourself you cannot
just reason your way a priori into
understanding why these people have
these clearly problematic ideas right
whether it's innocent as in different uh
versions of quantum mechanics or
something perhaps more darker uh in
politics or social circles
so i started thinking about that
interdisciplinary engagement in academia
and of course the one that i care about
is the relationship between physics and
philosophy right
those are the two areas that i actually
think about
uh at a research level myself uh
certainly the most and maybe even you
could say that was the only ones that
i've been successful at um and they have
guess what a problematic relationship
physics and philosophy i
completely coincidentally while thinking
about this came across stephen
weinberg's uh article his piece which i
think first appeared in the new york
review of books but anyway it was
reprinted in dreams of a final theory he
has a piece called against philosophy
you gotta love weinberg uh who we lost
this year he passed away uh a giant of
physics but uh even though i disagreed
him about some things including his
views on philosophy
he at least sat down and thought about
it you know we don't need to name names
there's plenty of scientists out there
today who will just know zero about
philosophy and poopoo it uh just to get
some cheap laughs weinberg wasn't like
that you know he would say why he
thought that philosophy was not worth
taking
too seriously as a physicist but he
would say it after having thought about
it very carefully you know weinberg was
one of the people who i uh recruited to
come to our moving naturalism forward
conference uh and he was you know he was
willing to do it you know he wanted to
talk to the philosophers who were there
but at the end of the day his position
was
no physicists should not be involved
with all this philosophy stuff and
i disagree with that uh so that is
something that i care a lot about
getting it correctly getting it right um
you know one way of putting my position
is you can't
not do philosophy that's a double
negative but you're always doing
philosophy okay but you can do it badly
and as soon as you hear scientists
explain why philosophy is not important
you're instantly witnessing them do
philosophy badly they will make
philosophical claims that have not been
thought through or have been thought
through hundreds of years ago and we
figured out you know what to say about
them and they just don't know okay
so it's a problematic relationship and
you know it there's obvious reasons why
there are differences in style as well
as in substance between physics and
philosophy i mean there's a bad
caricature
that some people seem to think is real
that says that
physics or science more broadly is based
on data and hypotheses and you know we
put out ideas and we let them be knocked
down by experiments whereas philosophers
just sit in their arm chairs and think
and that's an outmoded way of thinking
that we should have given up on 500
years ago i'm not even going to respond
to that because that's just goofiness
that's just not knowing what is going on
plenty of physicists mostly sit in their
armchairs including myself plenty of
philosophers
engage with data in interesting ways but
more importantly
i think that there is a stylistic
difference not just this substantive
difference you know philosophers
dig very deeply into individual
questions they're very very patient the
joke that i made in my first trade book
from eternity to here is that
physicists
are always really baffled about why
philosophers can
spend so much time thinking about the
meanings of words
whereas philosophers are baffled about
how physicists can continually use words
without knowing what they mean
and i think it's a joke because when you
put it that way both positions seem kind
of reasonable right like who cares about
the meanings of the words but then again
how can you communicate if you don't
agree on what those meanings are on that
side of the divide the philosophers will
be very very patient about really
nitpicking about the definitions of
every word and going deeply into it they
want to get everything crystal clear
right like no fuzzy bits that are we'll
clean up later
and for better for worse
that means they can get hung up you know
you can have philosophers talking about
questions that were hot topics thousands
of years ago and they still think is a
hot topic now and that can be very
frustrating to the scientists because
scientists physicists or whoever
their strategy is to dig just deeply
enough right i mean obviously physicists
do have to dig deeply when they're doing
their work but not too deeply if you've
ever if you're a physicist or you've
been a graduate student in physics or
whatever
not only quantum mechanics but
statistical mechanics and most
especially quantum field theory these
are areas of physics that are everywhere
right that are used all the time every
day
there's a lot of questions one can ask
in these areas that don't have clear
clean answers within modern physics
and the response of physicists is just
to move on get on with their lives say
ah it works it fits the data right
um
richard feynman won the nobel prize for
understanding how to renormalize quantum
electrodynamics and he never thought it
really worked he thought it was kind of
cheating and i think that a lot of
modern physicists post ken wilson etc
would say we understand why it worked
and that's better but you know they did
fine in the 1950s with uh this this
patchwork of things that just you know
kind of worked right what more do you
want
the good thing about being a scientist
or being a physicist is that since you
are working in an area where
you can ideally propose a theory and
have it tested by data on a relatively
short time scale
nature helps you right if you're asking
why science tends to make more progress
seemingly than philosophy does it's
because science cheats by having nature
correct it when it makes mistakes
that's a very very good way of making
enormously fast progress and you know
for example these days when we have
something like the standard model of
particle physics that is completely
compatible with the data
progress slows down in physics because
the data are not helping us as much as
they could
um
anyway so this is that is just to say
that it does make sense why there are
differences between physicists and
philosophers uh but there's also an
overlap
you know so often this question of
physics versus philosophy is phrased as
what good is philosophy for physics
right
why does do i as a physicist need to pay
attention to philosophy now that's a
completely wrong way of putting it i
mean who says that
the usefulness of any other field is
what it can do for your field that's not
necessarily the right way to do it we
should ask what good is philosophy for
its own sake not just what it can do for
physics
we could equally well ask what can
physics do for philosophy and my view
is that in both cases what can
philosophy do for physics and what can
physics do for philosophy there is a
small but crucial overlap
most physics can get by perfectly well
without any input whatsoever from
philosophy most philosophy can get by
perfectly well without any input
whatsoever from physics
but
it's
pretty darn clear to me that there are
specific questions within physics that
are also within philosophy
um in fact the i do think that there's
sort of a systematic mistake here that
people are making but um
when we think about questions that
physicists care about you know many of
them are like i said no philosophy
whatsoever if you want to figure out the
phase diagram of some new material
philosophy is not going to be helpful
but in exactly the areas of physics that
i care about in cosmology and quantum
gravity and fundamental physics
there are questions that philosophers
understand at least as well if not
better than physicists do questions
about what does naturalness mean how do
you reason anthropically in large
universes what is the nature of the
arrow of time and causality and locality
what are the issues and potential
solutions to problems with the
foundations of quantum mechanics or
statistical mechanics these are areas
where philosophers have thought deeply
about them and physicists tend to gloss
over them because that's what
philosophers do they think deeply now
they're not that great at coming up with
solutions
because they're philosophers they're not
scientists right it's not their job to
come up with solutions the philosophers
are really really good at diagnosing the
problems they're much better than the
physicists are physicists are good at
ignoring problems when they're not
absolutely necessary for them to be
confronted
but philosophers know that these
problems are there and they you know try
to
categorize what all the different
possible approaches are etc and what
would really be great
is if physicists and philosophers really
worked together at these intersection
regions right um and the truth is that
they don't
uh there's a little bit of overlap you
know there's there's uh some good
counter examples to this wild
generalization i'm pushing right here
especially in quantum mechanics that's a
the one area of physics philosophy
overlap where they're really both
physicists and philosophers who talk
about it but
it's not as if every physicist who does
quantum mechanics has any idea what the
philosophers are talking about um
and and they could you know i recently
saw a paper that surveyed the opinions
of physicists on
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
it's just embarrassing how little
factually physicists know about the
different approaches whether it's
copenhagen or hidden variables or many
worlds or whatever they're just very
very basic mistakes
that physicists make because they don't
know what's going on some of them know
they don't know what's going on like
there's a substantial number of people
who say i don't know
but there were too many people who
thought they knew and was wrong uh and
philosophers likewise philosophers have
their own
workshops conferences what have you and
don't always talk to physicists and so
as a result of that
the questions that are within the domain
of foundations of physics like like i
mentioned naturalness anthropics etc are
not necessarily the ones that
philosophers are training their keen
minds upon because
they're they don't move around as
quickly as the physicists do jumping
from topic to topic so you know they'll
have their favorite problems they'll
think of them for a very long time
there's plenty of room for improvement
in the interaction between physicists
and philosophers
and probably this is a paradigm right
for interactions of all sorts of you
know different kinds of things between
economics and history and literature and
what have you so
that was where i was literally
24 hours ago as i'm recording this
message i thought okay i'll do a little
uh holiday message talk about that for a
few minutes
and then i came home i was remember i
was in boston i spent uh the semester at
harvard visiting the philosophy
department it was a good visit by the
way in case you're wondering um but it
wasn't perfect because we're in the
middle of a pandemic
and i had things to do so it was a
little bit of piecemeal the extent to
which i could interact with people you
need to like set up an appointment right
rather than just bumping into people in
the hallways most people were staying at
home for most of the time which makes
perfect sense to me and i do not
begrudge them that and it looks like
maybe it'll be worse next semester i
don't know so maybe it was good that i
did it this semester but anyway i came
home uh and i was exhausted so because
you know you had to pack up it's a whole
big thing now i'm home in los angeles
with the wife the kittens it's all good
but chilling a little bit right you know
trying to relax
and for reasons that are not perfectly
clear to me um we now own two very
beautifully illustrated books that are
about making cocktails
that we didn't have these books when i
left for boston four months ago and now
we have them one i i actually do know
because i ordered it uh from the aviary
in chicago now i've never been to the
aviary
but it is the sort of cocktail bar
spin-off of elinia which is my favorite
restaurant in the world which i've been
to several times in chicago i love elini
to death very inventive
top-notch modern gastronomy and i love
going there whenever i can so the idea
of a cocktail version of that is
fascinating to me and i haven't been to
chicago for obvious reasons for a little
while um but i thought i could at least
buy the book see what they're doing that
was fun and then there's also a book by
this bar in new york called death and
company which i think is a great name
but it's really just a cocktail book and
i don't know why we have it it's
possible i ordered it it's possible
jennifer ordered it it's possible as a
gift from a friend we just can't
remember
we get a lot of books between jennifer
writing uh for ars technica and me
having a podcast etc people send us
books i don't think that uh anyone in
the cocktail world has us on their
mailing list but maybe they could add it
to it after this anyway
so i'm
enjoying like leaving through these
books it's a bad thing to do to read
cocktail books um in the morning
because you're inspired to want a
cocktail and that's not a good thing to
have first thing in the morning but uh
it's been a lot of fun just sort of
leafing through is exactly what my brain
needed you know not thinking about
physics or philosophy or moving or covet
or anything like that just you know
reading some recipes about cocktails
i personally
love cocktails it's a big
source of enjoyment for me
although i cannot drink too many of them
you know
i know that alcohol is a whole
problematic difficult subject in many
different ways i'm sure that many of you
don't drink alcohol at all some of you
drink a lot of it okay i'm in between
um i do like both wine and cocktails not
really a beer person but in the right
circumstances that would be fine also
different people of course react
differently to drinking and so let me
just say a couple words just so it's on
the table there
i'm the kind of person and jennifer also
is who could have a couple drinks and
then that's it
like we don't want any more than that
probably jennifer's at a level of two
drinks in the over the course of an
evening maybe i'm at three
but it's really not just that uh we have
the restraint to then stop you know once
we have a certain amount of alcohol in
our system we do not want to imbibe
anymore
and that's a good thing and there's
there's actually sort of two different
uh thresholds that people have and there
is interesting research on the genetics
of this because in some cases you can
pinpoint
mutations in the dna that are
responsible for these two different
things so one thing is
how quickly you get
inebriated right like how many drinks
does it take before you're intoxicated
the second one is once you've had a
couple what is your response and some
people shut down like that that's enough
other people want to keep going
there are things out there called
alcoholics um famous there's a famous
soliloquy by leo on the west wing if you
if you're a west wing fan where he
explains he's an alcoholic and it's a
plot point on the show because that's
was considered bad
uh and he says the problem is i don't
want to drink i want ten drinks
to a non-alcoholic like me that's just
crazy i can't even imagine having that
many drinks and there is a genetic
lottery as catherine paige hardin would
have explained to us that it comes into
this because i actually have plenty of
alcoholics in my family you know my
grandfather would literally have a
little glass of brandy that he would put
on the nightstand by his bed
before going to bed so that in the
morning he'd get a quick drink and you
know never not be buzzed during the day
it's very very different than me let's
just put it that way okay so i'm not
drinking too much
i mean by some people's standards i
drink a lot by other people's not that
much but i love the idea of cocktails
and i love the artistry of it and the
craft of it though the crucial
distinction we're drawing here is
between a cocktail which is a mixture of
different ingredients
versus you know a just a drink of some
particular spirit right a shot of
whiskey or a snifter of brandy or cognac
or something like that those are also
great
there's a place in time for having a
shot of scotch okay
but a cocktail is a little bit more
artistry you know you have to pick and
choose ingredients and you have to blend
them in the correct way and of course
like any good craft the people who are
truly into it will
get very very into it right they will
get very very detailed and the writers
of these two books the one from the
aviary the other from death and company
they're into it so you know what kind of
ice you use and whether or not you
should stir it or s or
shake it in a
metal
carafe or a glass one you know all these
things they matter a lot okay the
quality of the water it all matters a
lot and i'm not nearly that level of
caring but i am at the level of
appreciating
the care you know it's not just about
cocktails that's why i'm happy to talk
about cocktails here even though many of
you are not into cocktails at all
there's a bigger
picture there's a bigger point to this
which is that
all sorts of different crafts can be
appreciated for their artistry even if
we don't actually appreciate the outcome
maybe you don't like oboe music you know
i don't mind oboe music but i'm not
exactly a fan of it um david politzer my
my colleague caltech
loves the banjo literally just loves the
banjo writes papers writes physics
papers about the acoustics of banjos
he's played banjo with steve martin
who's another banjo lover
i don't love the banjo but i think it's
wonderful and charming that he loves the
banjo that much okay that's what's going
on here it's about the love it's about
the the care and the precision and the
sort of experimentation with different
possibilities that
trying to find some sweet spot
that makes the perfect cocktail the
perfect banjo diddy uh etc
and this does deserve you know it
probably deserves a whole podcast by
itself because it gets wrapped up in the
idea of fitness landscapes i love
fitness landscapes originally the idea
from biology of course
i talk about this in the big picture
i'm not sure if we talked about fitness
landscapes in great detail but they come
up in the podcast conversations that
have game theory
involved in them like with kailyn
o'connor and herb gintus and so forth
the idea of a fitness landscape is if
you have a again comes from originally
biology evolutionary biology so you have
a population
of different kind of uh species
different kind of individuals within a
species
and
they do evolution right so they sexually
reproduce share their dna there's
mutations so there's slow variations in
the actual genomes of the actual
individuals over time
some specific instantiations of the
genome will have slight advantages when
it comes to surviving and reproducing
that's what fitness means fitness is
just the ultimate the ability to pass
down
your genes to the next generation so you
need to both survive long enough to have
offspring and then be both motivated and
able to make those offspring okay
and the interesting thing about the
fitness landscape so the idea is that
the you know a species will evolve to go
upward and upward on the fitness
landscape over time until they hit some
local maximum
um
it's funny because biologists think that
high
values of a landscape is where you want
to live physicists who think of
potential energy think that low values
of a landscape is where you want to live
but that very similar concept
anyway the thing about the fitness
landscape that's always fascinated me
is the fact that the peaks of it
can be isolated from each other it's not
a smooth monotonic function it's not
like you can take two very different
species who are individually successful
and find a species halfway in between
that is also successful right
the specific things about a genome that
works if it's one kind of configuration
wouldn't work if it's slightly different
but if it's very different you're in
another peak of the fitness landscape
and you can also be successful
likewise with cocktails or with
novels or pieces of music or
food dishes that you're making there's a
fitness landscape right you can easily
imagine different ingredients working
together and half of those ingredients
with half of the ingredients from
another dish being a terrible disaster a
certain kind of arrangement for a string
quartet would not help at all if you
added some of those ideas to a heavy
metal song okay
so the the sort of
jaggedness of the fitness landscape is a
fascinating fact to me i would i would
love to know more about the general
theory behind why fitness landscapes are
jagged in the context of men of uh
cocktails it's that you know certain
ingredients work well with each other
and this is the whole point of cocktails
and why they're interesting i i don't
know if i yeah so a cocktail i was going
to say i don't know if i'd defined it
but a cocktail is just a mixture of
different ingredients different spirits
and some other liquid ingredients right
juices or whatever
maybe sodas
garnishes you can have things like that
and of course ice so you want to have
the right
ingredients balancing each other the
balance is crucially important and so
the only time i wrote about cocktails i
wrote a blog post that was complaining
about
the idea that is prevalent in certain
circles
that the best martini is the driest
martini okay so what does that mean for
those of you who are not cocktail
drinkers out there a typical martini is
mostly gin
some dry vermouth and then maybe a
garnish maybe a dash of bitters or
something like that but mostly it's you
know
gin plus driver move there's also of
course vodka martinis which are vodka
plus dry vermouth in the same sort of
combination
and
even though the vermouth is dry
sorry this is a
counterintuitive lingo but even though
the vermouth itself is dry
the less vermouth you have the drier the
martini okay so when you will hear in
different movies or tv shows or whatever
people trying to out macho each other in
the dryness of the martini so like just
a drop of vermouth or
wash the vermouth in the glass and then
dump it out before putting the gin in or
wave the bottle over your glass of gin
okay wave the vermouth bottle or
you know um just pour the gin in and
then nod in the direction of your bottle
of vermouth so it's like a kind of silly
competition to be as dry as possible but
that's dopey that's not right that's not
a good direction in which to
improve your cocktails because then
you're just drinking gin
or vodka which is even worse i mean
vodka is fine but vodka is more or less
flavorless
a shot of vodka can be good because it's
in some context where you're you know i
don't know eating uh dark bread in the
russian steps or something like that and
fermented fish and a shot of vodka okay
and then the
very very delicate differences between
different kinds of vodka and the mouth
feel etc can matter but if you're just
pouring cold vodka into a martini glass
and calling that a martini what's the
point that's not a cocktail at all it's
not even very flavorful
gin is basically vodka plus botanicals
mostly juniper but other sort of
botanicals that's why different kinds of
gin are truly different from each other
because every gin has its proprietary
mix of botanicals that lend some flavor
some herbaceousness or floral notes to
the underlying vodka some neutral grain
spirit aka vodka roughly speaking
so i wrote this blog post to say look
drink whatever you want i don't care
what you drink you know bring whatever
brings you pleasure is great but there's
no superiority in making a martini that
has only gin or only vodka in it that's
just saying you like gin any like vodka
that's fine
but the elegance the beauty the point of
a good cocktail is the balance of the
different ingredients it's not just that
you have different ingredients is they
play well with each other in a
particular way okay uh in fact let me
read to you so just so this podcast
episode is useful to you in some way you
will come around you'll come away from
it with uh recipes for cocktails so let
me read to you the martini and manhattan
recipes from the death co cocktail book
so
mart you don't want any recipes from the
aviary cocktail book they involve you
know high pressure machines and you know
crazy dry ice concoctions they're a
little bit crazy but it's an aesthetic
accomplishment but the death co uh
cocktail book you can actually make
these drinks so the martini is two and a
half ounces of london dry gin three
quarters ounces dolan dry vermouth
one dash of orange bitters and you
garnish with a twist okay so the point
there is two and a half ounces of london
dried gin three quarters ounces of dry
vermouth about a three to one ratio
not
a hundred to one as the um
uh crazy out there extremists would have
you believe the manhattan meanwhile uh
follows the same template there's a
major spirit there's a minor spirit sort
of play off against it and then maybe a
drop or two of something else so the
manhattan recipe is two and a half
ounces of rye three quarters of an ounce
of sweet vermouth which is the red
vermouth for those of you buying in
stores two dashes of bitters and garnish
with a branded branded cherry so
what struck me here is two things number
one the proportions are the same in the
martini and the manhattan they're very
different drinks uh completely
non-overlapping
ingredients in fact but
two and a half ounces three quarters
ounces and a dash or two
if you squint a little bit you could
almost perceive a power law
in these proportions it's almost like
you know a certain amount and three
times of that and three times as much as
that right start with the bitters work
your way up to the gin and the rye
some people will also by the way use
bourbon rather than rye in their
manhattans just like people sometimes
use vodka rather than gin and martinis
whatever you like the point is that
there's a certain amount of complexity
and interest here in the manhattan and
the martini this is one of the reasons
why they are classic cocktails
over many generations people have tried
many different
combinations of the different
ingredients and they've settled more or
less in the good bars
they've settled on something like this
three to one ratio for these particular
drinks other drinks will have two to one
ratios etc it is rare
to find a classic cocktail that has
equal proportions
in different kinds of spirits the
negroni is a classic counter example the
negroni is the one drink a negroni is a
one part gin one part campari or aperol
and one part sweet vermouth it works
very very well but it's the exception it
is not the rule most good cocktails have
a base spirit and then you complexify it
a little bit by adding these others in
greater or lesser amounts
that's the fun the artistry the science
and the aesthetics of making the
cocktails and the aesthetics are very
very important here one of the things
about both of these books is that
they're richly gorgeously sumptuously
illustrated and just looking at the
pictures of both the bar and the
cocktails when they're well made the
different shapes of the glasses
is it pretentious or precious you know
maybe i don't care i like it it's
beautiful and i i need more beauty
rather than less in my life
so while thinking about this
contemplating it while going geez this
is uh 10 a.m i can't actually make
myself a martini so i will contemplate
the aesthetics of it from an abstract
sense
i said you know
the holiday message for the blog for the
sorry for the podcast the holiday
message shouldn't necessarily be some
ponderous weighty idea like
interdisciplinary collaboration or
something like that maybe the holiday
message would just be kind of fun and
lighthearted maybe i should just talk
about cocktails
and i thought about it and i'm like
you know i i just don't know enough
about cocktails probably you would be
alienating for a bunch of people like
maybe you'll listen to me babble about
it for 10 minutes but talking for an
hour about cocktails might be too much
for a lot of people like even the
wine tasting i think more people
probably like wine than cocktails but
the wine tasting episode we did even
though it was extremely good and
successful it was not as popular as you
know
category theory episodes or loop quantum
gravity episodes so i get that and you
know give the people what they want
maybe maybe someday we'll do a
uh mixology based episode but uh i
thought that i didn't know enough to
talk about it in an intelligent way like
i have my preferences but i'm not a
professional mixologist i don't have one
nearby
so i thought that you know okay maybe
that would not be as attractive as the
idea first appeared to be but then i
thought and maybe this is because i had
managed to intoxicate myself even
without having a cocktail i thought
maybe i can do both
maybe i can mix up as it were the idea
of the interdisciplinary uh
collaborations in academia with the idea
of cocktails after all
in some sense
it's about balance and about interaction
right i mean this is why you don't want
to have a martini that is all gin
because jen is fine but it's just gin
it's not
interesting and it's not boundary
pushing it's not trying to do something
right it's not having different elements
in communication with each other talking
to each other bouncing ideas pushing in
different ways right that's what makes a
great cocktail when there's a little bit
of sweetness a little bit of bitter a
little bit of smoothness a little bit of
edginess there that's what makes the
most successful cocktails as any
mixologist will tell you it's about
balancing different kinds of ingredients
you don't want to mix together things
that taste the same right
having said that there are some very
provocative
recipes in the death co cocktail book
that mix
mezcal with tequila which are often
thought of as two different versions of
each other but are subtly different and
they have also different cocktails
mixing different kinds of rum together
so anyway every rule has its exception
but the point being
there is some family resemblance maybe
arguably
between the idea of disciplines in
academia talking to each other and the
different ingredients in a cocktail
talking to each other maybe physics
needs philosophy like gin needs vermouth
to make a good cocktail not because you
want to be mostly vermouth or all
vermouth but it adds that little twist
that really makes it special something
not just run-of-the-mill
and i think that's you know
that not becoming run-of-the-mill i
think that's the
important thing here when we going back
to the idea of disciplines and physics
and philosophy so forget about physics
and philosophy particularly think about
disciplines within academia more broadly
the real issue about disciplines is that
they become too inwardly focused you
know herb guintas on the podcast with
him he made this point very very loudly
and very effectively
um
it's part of what makes academia
successful what the the modern
university system successful
but it also holds it back in certain
ways okay
if you think about a department at a
university whether it's physics or
economics or
sociology or whatever how do they work
how do these departments work and for
various reasons historical reasons and
mostly for good reasons departments are
governed by their own faculty
the administration of the university
plays an important role but a lot of
times that role is you know fundraising
recruiting new students and and things
like that
usually the provosts and deans and
presidents will have some say over how
much a new department can hire
but to a very large extent who they
actually hire is in the hands of the
existing faculty members in the
department caltech's president literally
told me like i'm the president i know
perfectly well not to tell the faculty
who to hire not to tell the departments
who to hire and that's because you know
this is a it's for many reasons part of
it is academic freedom right you don't
want to be governed from the top the
reason why the modern intellectual
academic project is successful is
because it bubbles up from the bottom
and you want to be able to
judge for yourself as a department what
are the areas you need to grow in what
are the good areas what are the areas
that are a waste of time or a fad or
whatever you think you know that better
than the president or the dean or the
provost does and for the most part
universities say okay that that's right
you know we'll tell you how many slots
you get you can roughly speaking decide
how to fill them
so that works to some extent
it works really really well at that
focusing in on the different discipline
a physics department will be pretty darn
good at hiring new physicists biology
department will be pretty good at hiring
new biologists etc where it fails
is when the physics department wants to
hire a biophysicist
or even worse when
neither the physics department nor the
biology department wants to hire a
biophysicist because they want to both
hire their own people right
so it's as if you had a bar
where there's a set of bartenders who
only serve scotch
and another set of bartenders who only
serve gin and another set who only serve
tequila etc
those bartenders who only serve scotch
would get really good at choosing scotch
and it's actually not a perfect analogy
here because the disciplines are really
good at answering the questions that
they choose to focus on you know
i don't know what your opinion is but in
my opinion modern academic university
research is really good at the research
it chooses to be really good at doing
and likewise in the bar if you only
served cognac you get really good at
serving cognac etc but
you're missing out
on a whole set of more complex
interactions and experiences
the cocktails the mixtures of different
voices talking to each other in
different timbres and different volumes
and a university has trouble with that
the same system that makes it very very
successful at digging into the
disciplines makes it very very bad at
doing being truly interdisciplinary and
a lot of people give lip service to
being interdisciplinary but lip service
is not good enough
it's hard being truly interdisciplinary
um as herb guinta said on the podcast
you know the different disciplines not
only have different
subject matters sometimes they even have
the same subject matter but they have
different styles
different paradigms different ways of
asking questions different valuations of
which questions are interesting and
which are not
okay it makes interdisciplinary
conversation and communication very very
hard remember jeffrey west one of the
first guests we had here on the podcast
very successful complexity scientist at
santa fe institute he was raised as a
more or less traditional particle
theorist did supersymmetric
phenomenology he decided he wanted to
move into complex systems in particular
biological systems he got interested in
these allometric scaling laws why is it
that the metabolic rate and the weight
of different
kinds of animals different kinds of
individuals scales with each other in
certain ways especially
quarter power laws
why is that true was the question
so he said i got to talk to some
biologists i guess
but the point is
he it it took time
you know he tells the story of for weeks
and months they would just get together
and talk the biologists and the
physicists they weren't
giving each other instructions they
didn't even us decide ahead of time here
is the result we want to get or here's
the problem we're going to be working on
it's just let's listen to each other
let's hear
what each other thinks are the
interesting problems let's let's get to
know our
the common knowledge we have inside our
discipline that is not common outside
what are the assumptions we make what
are the things that we think are
important and not important you can only
learn that by talking to people going
back to the original point uh of the
tweet that i made back then
and
you have to decide ahead of time
that that's going to be a profitable
thing to do and it's just so easy to not
decide that
you know like when you get your phd
typically you've been very very well
trained in your very very narrow
specialty and it's work
to be trained in that specialty it took
you years right
and
now
you're good enough once you've been
trained with the phd you're good enough
in that specialty to write papers in
that specialty and get a job and do
research
to
now at this late stage learn another
discipline
it's going to be just as much work
and you don't have to do it because you
can just do the work you're already
doing and this is why most people most
professors despite the fact that they're
smart people
best of intentions good natured
always originally driven by some kind of
intellectual curiosity
why most professors kind of do small
variations on the thing they started
doing when they first entered academia
it's it's the path of least resistance
and it's successful you do learn things
you do dig deeply
into particular ways of knowing as it
were
but i would argue that
there's a downside to this and one of
the downsides is because precisely
because not just the substance of what
you know is different from discipline to
discipline but your normative
orientations that is to say how you
judge different things is different
like i said the problems you think are
interesting the methodologies you think
are legitimate just the vocabulary you
use from discipline to discipline can be
very very different and what this means
is that you can be
you know by nature intellectually
curious and smart
and by the fact that you have been
trained and honed within your discipline
you can become dismissive of other
disciplines because they don't sound
like yours you've been trained that a
certain kind of thing is right and good
and virtuous and those people are
talking about something else
and it becomes very very easy to just
dismiss them rather than to listen
to dig in to understand what they're
saying uh you just say ah
i want scotch they're trying to
give me tequila i'm not gonna listen to
those people they're a waste of time
it's remarkable how much
of academic discourse or academic
thinking let's let's put it that way is
arguably anti-intellectual
it's pro their own little kind of
intellectual endeavor but you become
poisoned against the broader
intellectual process because you're so
specialized in your own little area
uh and i would argue
that almost every discipline almost
every area has something of value in it
whether it's string theory
deconstruction austrian economics
whatever whatever area of
specialization you have in academia
most for the most part there's something
worthwhile in there even if there are
other things that are not worthwhile
even if you think that the people in
those areas um are largely
off the beaten track
not doing useful work
there's a whole bunch of smart people
who have of their own free will decided
that this is the area they want to dig
into and they're not evil
they're not motivated by greed or
whatever you know being a professor even
the best paid professors uh could be
paid more doing other things right
likewise for fame and fortune um
they got into this because they think
it's interesting and it teaches them
something about the world and so it goes
back to the idea that we should listen
to people's own reasons for believing
whatever it is they believe
we should take seriously the idea that
every discipline has something of value
and we can't really judge it until we
give it a chance to work its way into
our hearts and our brains so that we
understand why anyone would ever think
that has value
and that's hard that is hard to do and
so people don't do it generally it's
much easier just make fun of disciplines
that you're not in whatever those
disciplines may be i've certainly heard
philosophers make fun of physics let's
put it that way
and again the whole setup the whole
scheme generally works pretty well
progress is made in the individual
directions in which people are moving
the problem the failure mode is when a
discipline becomes insufficiently
self-critical
or insufficiently engaged with external
reality when it becomes too
inward-looking when it starts judging
its own successes
on criteria that only it understands
right and this can happen and i'm not
going to pick out any particular
disciplines different people will have
different ideas about this but i want to
pick out the general phenomenon
if you don't engage with very very
different points of view you can get
stale
you can pick up a certain set of things
that you valorize as successes
and people within your field are very
good at those things and it becomes
harder for you to say yes but
are those the values that we should care
about the most right
um
and
it's it's understandable
again i'm not like trying to say bad
things about people it's understandable
why you would think this because
if you're an expert in some area it's
really hard to trust the opinions of
non-experts about your area
and i'm not talking now about you know
epidemiology or virology or other hot
topics i'm talking like thinking about
quantum mechanics right
someone says oh there's a measurement
problem in quantum mechanics and you're
an expert in quantum mechanics and
they're not are you going to listen to
them
economics right you're a macro
economist and someone says well
macroeconomics is built on a flimsy
chain of reasoning or whatever why would
you ever care what they think it's very
very hard to take seriously criticisms
from people who are not inside the
discipline
and i think that this uh philosophy that
i'm trying to promulgate here this is
this extends to bigger pictures i'm in
academia so i feel it in that context
but clearly as i started saying this
extends to political and social issues
the idea of listening to each other it
can be hard people don't want to do it
why should i listen to the wrong people
that doesn't sound like a good idea
but let me point out
that it's kind of crucial to the success
of the democratic project
right
part of the idea of democracy is that no
one has the right answers fundamentally
like if there was a
particular identifiable subgroup of
people who had all the right answers
then just put them in charge that's what
plato wanted to do right with the
philosopher kings
democracy comes from a different angle
democracy says you know different people
have different interests
uh different things they want to be the
case maybe they have different expertise
and different knowledge bases remember
the podcast interview i did with henry
farrell where he talked about democracy
as a problem-solving mechanism and it
goes back to the
uh fitness landscape idea
problems can be hard to solve and very
often uh it is good when you're trying
to solve problems to have a diversity of
approaches tackling the problem if
there's a localized peak in the fitness
landscape and you have a problem-solving
technique that never points you in the
direction of that localized peak you're
less likely to succeed
than a group of people who are being
more ecumenical
so i think that
there is not just
something to be done academically uh
increasing our generation of knowledge
within uh the intellectual machinery
that we have in our society by having
more interdisciplinary work i think it's
also a model for our conversations more
generally
it's not you know you can always be too
extreme about this you know as i like to
say on the podcast uh or when i talk
about people i invite on the podcast
i
want to invite diverse people i want to
invite people not only whom i agree with
but i don't want to invite people who
are a waste of time
i want to invite people who even if i
disagree with them i think that they
it's worth listening to them
and my personal judgment about what is
worth listening to might not be yours
yeah that's why there's more than one
podcast out there but i do think that
the general philosophy
of
listening to different kinds of points
of view
opens you up to insights and solutions
to problems that you wouldn't otherwise
have
just like
opening yourself up to mixing different
spirits together
leads to the possibility of a better
better cocktail look i know just as well
as you do this is not the world's best
analogy okay but there it's the holiday
message it's supposed to be fun it's
supposed to be light-hearted and i
wanted to like have something
substantive in there and also be
lighthearted so that uh served the
purpose a little bit think of the
discussion of being interdisciplinary
within academia as the
base spirit as the gin in the martini or
the rye in the manhattan and think about
the the talking about cocktails etc as
the complementary spirit i don't know if
there's a word for that there probably
is like i said i'm not an expert in
mixology uh so there probably is a
specific technical word for whatever
that secondary spirit is that adds some
extra color
uh extra nuance to the whole concoction
as a whole
besides cocktails are fun and talking to
people is hard talking to people you
disagree with sometimes it's not worth
talking to them you never know
some people are the farinay branca of
opinions uh other people get along a lot
of times but it's worth the effort you
know
as much as steven weinberg was a
brilliant guy i do wish that he
appreciated a little bit more that for
certain
questions within physics there's
something to be gleaned from the points
of view that philosophers have to offer
and likewise for certain questions in
philosophy there's something to be
gleaned from what physicists have to
offer
there's something to be gleaned
between biologists and economists and
linguists and the whole bit computer
scientists it's hard to do and i think
that as a system
we don't
create mechanisms by which it can happen
we have a system that is really really
good at the disciplines
not so focused on letting
interdisciplinary work go that's not a
cocktail bar that i want to go to i want
one that has uh fun combinations of
different things that surprise me and
lead me to places that uh i've never
been before maybe that's what i'll do
right now who knows
anyway
as the point of the holiday message
thank you so much for listening to the
mindscape podcast uh this has been going
on you know it's been a more regular
thing than i thought when i started what
two and a half years ago uh mindscape i
thought you know i said i'll start
trying to do it once a week but i
probably won't succeed in doing that and
here we are we're succeeding
i have a whole bunch of podcasts in the
can that are really really good quite
pretty diverse actually um always trying
to become a better podcaster better
questions better guests and things like
that better audio quality i know the
audio quality comes and goes
i do care about it i do try to make it
good but there's a fundamental
constraint that the if i do a remote
podcast
then i don't control the room that the
other person is in even if i get them a
microphone if they're in an echoey room
it can be very very hard to get good
audio quality
just letting you know that i i feel your
pain when the audio quality is not up to
snuff i do try to make it good and it's
been great for me you know it's been
it's work it's a certain amount of
effort um especially when i had to like
understand the point of view of someone
talking about some esoteric topic
but that's the biggest single reason i
do it so that i can be exposed to these
different ideas you know maybe every
faculty member should be forced to have
a podcast in which they interview people
outside their own domain of intellectual
expertise because that would that would
lead them
to appreciate what other people have to
offer and you know that's a pretty good
holiday message right there
thanks for listening here's hoping your
2022 is challenging and rewarding in the
best possible ways
[Music]
you